but let's let's read your number three
i'm gonna natalia can you put that up on
the screen yes so the audience has it
any woman who makes you wait for sex or
by her actions implies she is making you
wait for sex the sex is never worth the
wait
okay so first i'm going to give you an
opportunity to expand
what why so and what do you mean by that
okay so first first and foremost the
reason why i put that as an iron rule
now here you have to explain to you
exactly what the iron rules are okay um
they're not
they're not suggestions they're not
always having suggestions but they're
not like
follow these nine steps to a perfect
life because everybody wants a
step-by-step 12 rules for life 12 you
know seven easy tips to have publishers
tell you to write like that perfect yeah
to have the perfect life just follow
these easy because everybody wants a
step-by-step guide so i have to point
that out in the very beginning here that
when i was writing these these all all
of my writing comes from
uh the forum era as well like what i
like to call it i used to be a moderator
on a form called so suave and so all of
the stuff that it's in all of my books
really but certainly everything that's
in the first book
uh are derivatives from having
conversations for over the course of
like about 10 years with guys who are
coming together in what was known as the
seduction community at that time it was
puas and was you know we called it you
know
mystery method and neil strauss and all
that stuff it was a very small c yes
today by today's standards we think of
it as sort of like the golden era like
oh that was then this is now kind of
thing um
but all of the conversations that we
were having at that time
ended up becoming uh essays that i was i
think of myself more as like an essayist
rather than a blogger because if you
look at my blog it's really more it's
it's not about what's going on my life
it's here's what's going on from the
conversations i've been having so a lot
of the stuff that's in the red uh the
original rational mail is from aggregate
conversations that we had over the
course of like 10 years on these blogs
so that's number one
number two is this is that so the the
principle of of iron rule number three
is about genuine desire so it's not
about go and bang anything on two legs
and that's the first thing anybody
thinks of like well you don't want a
girl to think you're easy or a girl
doesn't want you know guys to think that
she's easy you know play hard to get be
a coquette like coca-tree is the is the
operative term there but um that's not
what it's about it's about genuine
desire what does that mean genuine
is the implication that if a woman
desires you she will act on it and if
she doesn't desire you she will not is
that what you're saying it's motivation
uh to become intimate on the part of a
woman and too many guys will sell
themselves short
on a
because most guys don't get laid most
guys don't especially today we have the
lost boys generation
a lot of guys today just simply it's a
it's a foreign thought for them to be
able to do what i call spinning plates
which is dating non-exclusively which
i'm sure we'll get into later on oh yeah
okay we're going to get that done um so
as far as as as iron rule number three
is concerned it's uh it's not about the
go and have sex with as many people as
you possibly can it's about
understanding genuine desires why do you
assume that if if a woman decides to
wait and not have sex instantly that
they don't desire you because i don't
think that's because it becomes because
it becomes a posi you get yourself into
a position of negotiating desire and
when you're negotiating desire it
one of the operative points again in the
book is you cannot negotiate genuine
desire that's not negotiating desire
though let me give you an example i'm a
woman who
i was raised by a dad and a mom who
worked together for many years and my
dad taught me from a very young age
about self-respect he instilled in me
that
your body is your temple and you should
respect your body if you don't respect
your body nobody else is going to
respect your body so from a very i never
had a fling phase i never ever had a one
time called the whole face i've never
had a whole face never had a one night
stand in my life every single person
that i slept with meant something to me
i wasn't in love with them all but i was
in deep like it had value to me there
were guys that i went out on dates with
who i desired plenty i desired playing
but i wanted to give an image how did
you express that desire to them
i was affectionate
i was flirty with them
i was
very clearly interested eye contact body
language all of that was coming into
play
but i needed a minute to make sure that
meant something because i wasn't willing
to give my body to let someone inside my
body which i have a lot of self-respect
for unless it was real unless it had
value for one main reason first of all i
have self-respect secondly i wasn't
raised like that and thirdly a lot of
women don't get anything out of the sex
if they're not emotionally connected so
i was like wow this guy's really cool i
like his energy this happened to me a
number of times i like what he's about i
think he's confident i think he's sexy
this is all very appealing to me let me
feel this out and just make sure there's
something real here because i'm not
going to put my body into it my soul
everything unless it's real unless he's
really into me i'm really into him it
wasn't a power struggle it wasn't about
i'm gonna withhold this and make him
want it none of that was going into play
to be 100 honest ever i don't play games
like that i'm not interested in them i
think men can detect them and i think
they immediately size you up as playing
a game so i don't play games so there
are women that
i want to just nuance this and say there
are women that
hold that back not because they're
playing a power game or trying to
negotiate with matt because they really
have been raised right
women of your generation do i think that
in those terms so
so are you all
right well no no not necessarily you're
talking to me here
i am talking to you there i'm talking to
women who are you know from 15 all the
way up to 70 84. what do you say to
someone like me though so well what i
what i would say what i would say to you
is that most guys and one of the reasons
for this rule is most guys uh experience
a uh mitigation when it comes to sexual
desire so when we're talking about uh
genuine desire what i'm talking about is
something that's organic something that
you you have like when
a woman who is into you won't confuse
you okay so when guys tell me oh she's
sending me mixed messages i'm like no
she's not the medium is the message is
she flaking on dates she's different is
she telling you is she telling you one
thing and doing something else
this is the you know the byword of the
the manuscripts
what if it's not mixed measurement well
how does how does he know that again
what if it's somebody what if they
vocalize it
what if they're i'm up front in other
words i'll say it i'll vocalize it
because the vocalization of it is is
different from actually living it out
okay it's like i said the medium is the
message and like one of the things we've
been telling guys for ages and you know
it applies across the board really is
believe what she does not what she says
so if a woman is d is flaking on dates
that's the message that's different
that's the thing that's different than
someone who's not flaking on dates
someone who's showing up somebody's
showing up somebody who's interested so
like there are what if what if i mean
there are women like me i would say hey
i'm not dating around i'm not interested
in that i'm really interested in you
i'm just taking some time to get to know
you this is this is just how i grew up
a lot of the and i heard you talk about
this with adam as well is a lot of your
experience is of course anecdotal and
it's personalized and everything and i
know just only just you know a little
bit of of your background as far as
that's concerned but
we don't date like that anymore we date
online right now the number one way for
men and women to get together is online
is to hinge bumble tinder that's a
problem
um it's it's a problem but it's also an
advantage in some cases as well but
whether it's a problem or it's not
that's what we're dealing with right now
right if you like the short clip you can
catch another one here or you can catch
the full episode right here
[Music]